it's called a stoned ape theory yeah
that's how mckenna's
mushrooms i don't know the best guy
describing that is actually terence
mckenna's brother dennis and dennis is a
real scientist like a rock solid
scientist and the way he describes it he
explains
why
the theory has some merit he never says
that it's definitely what happened but
what is there
the mystery with the human brain size
is that the human brain size doubled
over a period of i think it's like two
million years which is extraordinary
right they have no idea what happened
right and so there's a lot of theories i
feel like my brain is trump
i feel like it's happening
it's a good time are you gonna take this
long i don't know yeah
[Laughter]
come
on god i thought we lost miles bro but
he's back he's back everything's good he
was just covered by the bottom andrew's
hallucinating yeah it's okay
let's go
so that's the theory we missed the whole
thing yeah i missed it
the
ancient primates yeah experimented with
mushrooms and they led to a rapid
development in human brain size which
doubled over a period of two million
years so the human brain size doubled
and he thinks it coincides with the rain
forest receding into grasslands which
would give to a lot of undulates that
would [ __ ] like cows and then on those
patties they would find mushrooms and
they would try them out as a food source
because kilt
[Music]
[Laughter]
you don't have to put pesticide in the
lab yes organic just means don't
pesticide
wait you only eat organic no i eat
whatever the [ __ ] i want to eat right he
ate six burgers when we were out that
one time oh yeah that is one time i did
now you understand why we talk about
food with you joe i like to eat we met
you to get a hamburger
yeah you ate three
and then there was one more on the table
and you just said this is nobody's right
[Laughter]
because sometimes they leave them there
because everybody's just ordering [ __ ]
we got like giant trays yeah you want to
be wasteful i think that was a chicken
sandwich too
i think you have insane recall and you
think that you're dumb but your recall
like are you one of the guys you could
you know exactly what happened in a
round of a fight that you watched 10
years ago not always no definitely not
all sometimes sometimes i get it yeah a
lot of times that's pretty crazy
sometimes i get it wrong sometimes like
oh i thought he did it that way hmm
like because you've heard athletes do
this like bill russell could could tell
you every single play of every game
lebron they say can do it i don't know
if i believe it
that's interesting sean mcveigh
fighters don't have that well they've
got a fighter's kind of goal
i assume no even when they win like
sometimes they just get in a zone and
then before they know it they've won and
then they'll watch it on camera and go
whoa look at that like almost like they
don't remember what they did i assume if
your life is on the line that's
everything is heightened but you don't
remember any of it it's just i have to
survive i don't think it's that as much
as they're so focused on delivering
shots
they're so focused on delivering shots
until they get a trance but what about
my theory
talking about the toughest people in the
world you're maybe you're just scared
theory would be great you don't think
akash would be a good fighter
a lot of people smart guys are good
fighters say again just a lot of really
smart guys well i was i didn't say he's
a very smart dude
actually the worst recall
yeah but you're smart man i'd be reading
[ __ ] and forgetting it in 30 seconds
every time y'all asked me for something
i talked about two weeks ago i'm like i
don't know man but
is that the case or is it just that you
don't give a [ __ ] about what they were
talking about like if something matters
to you do you remember i still forget
i'm dead ass dude i read
what every hindu holiday means every
year and then i forget the next time it
comes around but what if that's
something you like is important like
what if your wife is telling you
something that happened like i wasn't
listening in the first place
so what could you do you know
that's that's that's not well you won't
you see that
that's not good don't do that at home
seem to have a commitment to this
ideology
it's his [ __ ] fault he got me high
this chair goes back so far
[Laughter]
it does make me feel like like sitting
here like more casual it's more casual
it's chill yeah yeah like an office
chair i'm always in like these little
[ __ ] chairs that make you sit up like
this yeah yeah but don't these hurt your
back
get a little lumbar support if you need
it okay
guys that clip was brought to you by
blue chew best boners in the business
same active ingredients as cialis or
viagra but this is the true the only one
we rock with get yours for free at
bluetooth.com promo code andrew all you
gotta do is pay five dollars shipping